sehr gerne also es geht um luxuriöse
dienstwagen mit massagesitzen es geht um
teure beraterverträge und heimliche boni
und das alles auf kosten der
steuerzahler nicht der steuerzahler
sondern der gebühren zu wir waren gerade
weil steuern
die rbb affäre um patricia schlesinger
die ja empört die republik und die
erschüttert die ard das ist wohl die
größte der größte skandal in der langen
geschichte des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks ist so lange nicht zu ende
denn es gibt immer weitere enthüllungen
um verschiedene ard sender jetzt jungs
beim ndr da geht es darum dass
redakteure schwere vorwürfe gegen die
sendeleitung erhoben haben es wird
kritische berichterstattung teils
unterdrückt von politischem filter ist
die rede und ja wir können nur sagen
tatort ard es ist dringend zeit für
echte reform im öffentlich-rechtlichen
kunden welche maßnahmen schlagen sie
ganz konkret vor also es geht vor allen
dingen um erstens um die kontrolle was
ich erschreckend finde gerade bei in
diesem rbb fall war da gibt es gremien
wie den verwaltungsrat und den
rundfunkrat da sitzen viele leute drin
die eigentlich diese ganzen gelder
kontrollieren sollen aber das sind
teilweise amateure die waren ja auch
überfordert und sind mittlerweile auch
zurückgetreten dann ganz wichtig
transparenz ich habe als gebührenzahler
ein recht darauf nicht zu er hat nicht
nur zu erfahren was der intendant einer
ard-anstalt verdient sondern was kostet
eigentlich diese ganzen sendungen dort
was kostet eine florian silbereisen show
am samstagabend oder ein hirschhausen
spiel weiß man das nicht das ist nicht
offiziell bekannt gegeben worden bisher
es wird ein riesen geheimnis zb gemacht
um die pensionen die altersvorsorge im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk ist ja
sehr sehr üppig wir haben jetzt
recherchiert dass zum beispiel die rbb
direktoren die jetzt dort diesen ganzen
schlamassel zu verantworten haben dass
die teilweise bis zu
13.000 14.000 euro im monat in ihrem
medium den fall schlesinger aufgedeckt
ja und das war schon ein riesiger fall
auch herzlichen glückwunsch an business
insider immer gut wenn ihr presse
kontrolliert aber war das nur die spitze
des eisberges ja das ist tante war ja
dass dann sich die intendanten
hingestellt haben und sagen oh gott
schlimm was da beim rbb entstanden ist
und dann müssen wir das vertrauen
entziehen das ist natürlich alles ein
einzelfall ich kann mich noch gut daran
erinnern ist erst wenige tage her da hat
sich die intendanten des bayerischen
rundfunks einem interview hingestellt
und sagt alles singulär beim beim rbb
ist es gibt es nirgendwo anders und wir
bekommen jetzt wirklich sehr sehr viele
hinweise aus anderen ard anstalten gehen
den natürlich nach und wir sind ja jetzt
schon beim ende eher darauf gestoßen
dass es dort einflussnahme auf die
berichterstattung gibt ich weiß gar
nicht was schlimmer ist ob es die
gebührenverschwendung ist oder ob
sozusagen die eigentliche staatsferne
missbraucht wird wie läuft die
einflussnahme ab wird er angerufen
seitens der politik beim ndr oder wissen
sie da schon mehr aber ging es um
berichterstattung zum
cdu-ministerpräsidenten daniel günther
der hatte einen konflikt mit seinem
innenminister und dann wurde die
berichterstattung so gemacht dass der
daniel günther eigentlich den sie auch
alle daniel nennen im ndr
rundfunkrats dort in kiel wurde die er
so in richtung daniel günther getreten
da wohl wirklich kritische passagen das
finde ich wirklich erschreckend
kritische passagen wurden
herausgeschnitten und ist und dann wurde
das auch diskutiert intern immerhin es
wurde diskutiert und dann gab es massive
vorwürfe da wurde gesprochen von einem
politischen filter und dass die
cdu-landesregierung von diesem
landesfunkhaus geschützt werden sollte
jetzt ist ja letzte woche wieder auch
wieder jemand zurückgetreten vom mdr
landesfunkhaus chefin in sachsen-anhalt
weil ihr es plötzlich eingefallen dass
sie ehemann in eine betrugsaffäre vor
einigen jahren verwickelt worden ist und
also ich habe das gefühl jetzt dass wir
da wirklich richtig in ein wespennest
reingestopft jawohl sie haben ja die
situation auch dass es gibt ja themen
die auch wirklich dem renommee schaden
des öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks
nehmen sie den flug im regierungsflieger
nach kanada ja da ist ja in den
öffentlich rechtlichen medien das
narrativ
kritiklos verbreitet worden da war
juristisch alles in ordnung gespräche
jetzt mal als jurist ja ich weiß dass
mittlerweile der versuch gemacht worden
ist namhafte luft
verkehrsexperten dafür zu gewinnen zu
sagen ja das war alles richtig bislang
hat sich nur noch keiner gefunden nur
die berichterstattung die übertage so
gewesen ist ich will wissen gar nicht
worüber euch aufregt geht wie dermaßen
schlecht ja die gilt sowieso wieder das
ist ja nicht das thema aber es wird ja
behauptet im haupt ihm im
regierungsflieger war alles in ordnung
das ist juristisch oder falsch aber in
der ard gerade zdf konnten sie tagelang
hatte einfach das narrativ führen ist
alles juristisch in ordnung die dürfen
das also ich glaube und in der fans sein
verhalten glaube dass wir deswegen auch
auf der ich auf dem richtigen weg sind
da den finger in die wunde zu legen weil
wir bekommen sehr viel zuspruch auch von
den mitarbeitern im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk weil die sagen hat
ist total wichtig dass diese ganzen
geschichten mal ans tageslicht bekommt
weil da gibt es ja wirklich sehr sehr
viel glück haben ja auch viele
befristete verträge verdienen geld also
eher nicht dass jeder dort reichlich
reich schritt und gerade beim rbb gab es
ja die diskussion dass da sehr viel
gespart wird dass man überlegt wird
kommen die freien überhaupt zum zuge was
bekommen sie und so weiter werden sie
gebucht und dann bekommen sie auf der
anderen seite mit das ja die chefetage
man muss wirklich sagen in saus und
braus lebt jetzt ist aber nicht nur das
thema welche das kurz sagen darf der
frage der der der politischen kontrolle
oder ähnliches ist auch eine frage des
völlig überbordenden begriffs des
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks ja da
sind neun milliarden werden im jahr
ausgegeben nach meiner kenntnis für
etwas was ursprünglich
verfassungsrechtlich als grundversorgung
gedacht war ein nachrichtenprogramm ein
fernsehballett und einen sohn thomas
gottschalk über die generation
aber das ist man doch in der 25
in 25 facher ausfertigung das heißt also
dieser apparat der da gewachsen ist auch
mit billigung zum beispiel des
bundesverfassungsgerichts der ist im
prinzip überhaupt nicht mehr mit dem
grundgedanken der seinerzeit zur
gründung des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks geführt hat vereinbar das
grundproblem ist aus meiner sicht da
kommen wir einfach nicht drum rum ist
der pflichtbeitrag ja dass jeder zahlen
muss und sonst unter umständen sogar ins
gefängnis wandert wenn er es nicht tut
egal ob er es schaut oder nicht dass wir
also höchstrichterlich bestätigt ja
geradezu gefordert haben dass jeder
zahlen muss deutscher staatsbürger ist
viele vereine müssen zahlen unternehmen
müssen zahlen horrende summen teilweise
ich finde es wäre nur nötig eine
radikalkur da müssten allerdings
bundesverfassungsgericht und alle länder
mitspielen das werden sie nicht aber
wenn es eine radikale vorgeben würde
werden meine vier vorschläge erst das
zdf abschaffen das ist eine totale
doppelstruktur braucht kein mensch
die ard wiederum die drei mini sender
radio bremen soll den rundfunk rbb
abschaffen aber noch sechs statt neun
können wir den umliegenden gemeinden
dritter vorschlag beitrag halbieren es
reicht nämlich dann auch angebot auch
nur halb so groß und fitter vorschlag
pflichtbeitrag auf freiwilligen beitrag
um stellen sich auf dem freien markt
bewerben das ist dann wirklich gut dann
kann man sagen überzeugen durch
exzellenz und nicht durch moralische
pflicht den rundfunk 999 anbieten
anbieten ein gutes angebot machen und
warum soll ich ein gutes angebot nicht
nutzen ich bin dafür für die
öffentlich-rechtlich ich bin nicht nur
für sie abzuschaffen ist klar zu sagen
aber bitte radikal reduzieren auf den
kern das auch jeder in der deutlichkeit
ich würde es letztendlich ja ich zeige
auf amazon prime zurzeit natürlich würde
ich dafür für gute krimis zahlen für
gute unterhaltung für regionale
berichterstattung bliebe sonst keine
brinker er hat ja auch der rbb seine
meriten weil der regionalen
berichterstattung
aber es gibt ja auch eine diskussion
mittlerweile um das programm also dass
man wirklich sagt okay da wird das sind
ja über acht milliarden die dort zur
verfügung stehen plus werbung und dann
muss man sich natürlich überlegen wo
fließt das überhaupt hin und wenn ein
großteil zimmer oder nicht ein großteil
aber ein hoher zweistelliger bereich der
in die altersversorgung geht dann haben
wir einfach massives problem also muss
einfach gelten programm führt warum ist
es denn so dass viele jetzt amazon prime
oder netflix machen weil sie natürlich
mit dem angebot was von ard und zdf
kommt nicht zufrieden sind da laufen
dann irgendwelche
bozen krimis und istanbul krimis und so
weiter ist ja alles schön und gut die
wollen ja auch ihre quote haben ist ja
in ordnung haben ja aber warum ich mir
wünsche sind tolle dokumentation
hintergrundberichterstattung alle das
programm durch gehen wenn ich einmal
herein situation machen bei deinem leben
sendungen niemals enden also warum sie
wollen ja mit der linken vor allem
menschen entlasten in deutschland das
nehme ich auch ihrem parteiprogramm her
warum sind sie so still was den
rundfunkbeitrag betrifft wäre das nicht
eine entlastung für jeden haushalt zu
sagen vielleicht den vorschlag von herr
kessler also erstmal weg kurz sagen das
ist vollkommen richtig wir brauchen da
reform wir haben strukturen die seit
langen jahren sozusagen im bestehen und
struktur nein zur trägheit das heißt der
glocken werden ausgenutzt das heißt wir
brauchen da auf jeden fall die reform
das heißt wir brauchen auch mehr mit
einer sprache der mitarbeiter in der
emma freien bin ich von überzeugen und
vor allem die politik sollte sich ein
stück weit rausziehen ich halte
allerdings den rundfunkbeitrag für
absolut notwendig und richtig im sinne
des auftrags des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks ist ursprünglich
der grundversorgung das ist ein jetzt
bestätigt in dieser höhe ich finde es
richtig finde aber auch eine diskussion
über die frage qualität statt quote
nicht richtig weil in diesem grund
auftrag gehört eben dass man auch die
seite der recherche der der
dokumentation nachricht einmalige
leistung zeit habe aber das ist mir noch
eine sache ergänzende an dieser stelle
auch bei den privaten sendern ist es ja
durchaus so dass jede bürgerin jeder
bürger damit
bezahlt nämlich über die werbung
beiträge die einkalkuliert sind in die
printprodukte das heißt wenn ihr an sie
an die supermarktkette umgehen produkt
am kaufen was beworben wird ob im
supermarkt oder
doch sie doch reduzieren sich immer wenn
ja nicht direkt aber sondern es sehr in
die ecke
stellen
das ist ja belegt in allen budgets allem
unternehmen die sich über werbung
sozusagen publiziert ist ein werbebudget
am eingeplant da mehr über alte und
damit er machen die auch werbung ja ihr
müsst mann noch lebte oder nicht an
dieser stelle aber durchaus finanzieren
sich im privatsender auch im über die
allgemeine egal ob ich privatsender
schauer oder nicht
und jetzt zu vergleichen
sendern na ja ich gehe
zwar dass selbstbestimmung gesetzt